[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
francés 24 por estos días estamos
asistiendo al aniversario número 10 de
la denominada primavera árabe y es que
entre diciembre de 2010 y marzo del año
2011 países del norte de áfrica y
también de medio oriente experimentaron
masivas protestas ciudadanas con
intensidad y resultados muy diferentes
en cada país
millones de personas se manifestaban por
sus malestares compartidos pedían el fin
de sistemas de gobiernos
antidemocráticos y autoritarios
manifestaban además un hartazgo ante la
corrupción en sus países también ante la
impunidad la desigualdad y pedían
también libertad y justicia social entre
otras demandas las protestas comenzaron
en túnez pero se extendieron por toda la
región provocando la caída de
mandatarios que llevaban décadas en el
poder y saludamos ahora eduard soler le
echa aire sos doctor en relaciones
internacionales y especialistas en temas
del mundo árabe y medio oriente señal
sobre la leche a primer lugar muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
bueno 10 años después según su punto de
vista cuál es el saldo de aquellas
protestas que hicieron albergar
esperanzas no de un cambio real y
profundo
se ha producido cree usted un avance
general hacia quizás una mayor
participación y democratización política
ha habido enormes diferencias por países
las primaveras árabes fueron una ola de
protestas es un episodio sísmico con dos
epicentros uno en túnez otro en egipto
después una ola de protestas que alcanza
toda la región y la intensidad de la ola
fue distinta cuando llego a cada uno de
los países y la capacidad de acomodación
de estas protestas y la respuesta de
cada uno de los regímenes también fue
distinta por eso vemos situaciones en
que hay transiciones demográficas con un
alto nivel de frustración también que la
fuerza tiempo de producirse en
democracia y en sistemas autoritarios
como en túnez otras donde lo que vemos
la capacidad de acomodo
con reformas y otras en lo que ha
firmado es la represión o incluso el
conflicto y todo esto cuando lo miramos
diez años después hay elementos digamos
positivos hay una voluntad de cambio que
no ha desaparecido de hecho lo vimos en
las manifestaciones del 2019 que
volvieron a ocupar las calles de muchos
países árabes como argelia irak líbano o
sudán pero hay otros elementos
digamos negativos en este balance hay
mucha frustración ha habido mucha
violencia y ciertamente seguramente en
los promotores del cambio no han tenido
éxito pero los que está claro que sí que
subieron a conseguir sus resultados son
los que defendían el status quo que no
se produjera ese cambio la resistencia
al cambio la contraola autoritaria como
se ha llamado en algunas ocasiones
y esto es lo que hace que hoy en día una
parte importante del mundo árabe no sea
más libre sino que incluso sean menos
libres de lo que era en 2010
bueno como usted decía los procesos y
los escenarios no en cada país han sido
muy distintos pero destacaría ustedes
algún escenario como algún cambio
positivo digamos en términos concretos y
reales no
si hay cambios positivos en túnez mismo
a nivel político
a nivel económico y social está claro
que las expectativas de la población
tunecina no se han alcanzado las
protestas de 2011 no fueron sólo unas
protestas que expedían mayor libertad
que también también pedían a acabar con
un sistema de unidad de corrupción y
sobre todo querían esperanza tenían
oportunidad querían justicia social y
ahí por ejemplo pues mientras que en
túnez hemos visto avances positivos a
nivel democrático a nivel de formar las
estas expectativas de progreso no se han
producido pero después estamos viendo
algunos episodios muy interesantes a
nivel político derivados en parte de ese
aire de cambio empezó a soplar en 2011
aunque se ha concretado más tarde y es
por ejemplo lo que vemos con la
intensidad persistencia creatividad del
movimiento de protestas en argelia lo
que se conoce como el girar
actualmente y que está todavía vigente o
incluso la madurez y la capacidad de
aprendizaje de los movimientos de
oposición en sudán que apretaron no para
que se avanzara realmente en una
transición democrática después de la
caída de algo así con lo cual no todo es
negativo es cierto préstamos una
situación tan dramática cuando pensamos
en cosas como las de siria con más de
medio millón de muertos y millones de
refugiados y una década traumática no
sólo para los sirios sino para el
conjunto del mundo árabe pero también
hay elementos interesantes
en los que reflejar no siendo que la
población árabe va a continuar
reflejando sé que esa valentía para
levantarse cuando nadie lo esperaba y
esa creatividad persistencia e
innovación en los mecanismos de
movilización social y política ahora
edward en muchísimos países se pasó de
revueltas pacíficas a escenarios de
guerra no de guerra civil hablamos por
ejemplo del caso de libia de yemen de
siria por supuesto también a otros
países también experimentaron una suerte
por llamarlo de alguna manera de verano
democrático digamos pero luego volvieron
gobiernos más dictatoriales
a qué atribuye ustedes de estos procesos
lo atribuyo a varios factores el primero
es que muchas de las tensiones sociales
habían quedado sofocadas de alguna forma
era como una olla a presión y por lo
tanto en el momento en que saltó la tapa
pues allí se desparramó todo de alguna
forma es decir el hecho de haber
intentado mantener silenciadas ahogadas
estás dijo que en el momento en que
estallaran pues fueran más violentas y
emergen divisiones y agravios que habían
estado silenciados durante mucho tiempo
pero más importante todavía que este
elemento es la capacidad el éxito de los
partidarios del autoritarismo y de los
regímenes anteriores para manipular la
situación de forma que el cambio no
pueda posible y esto lo hemos visto en
mayor o menor medida en casi todos los
países en que se produjeron protestas
sólo allí donde ha habido una
persistencia más fuerte una capacidad
también de negociación más fuerte por
parte de la oposición pues digamos se ha
conseguido algunos avances positivos
pero cojamos el caso de siria vemos cómo
emergen unas protestas una clara
naturaleza democrática y pacífica pero a
golpe de represión parte de estas
protestas acaba derivando en una
insurrección armada porque no queda
tampoco otra o una parte importante de
esa posición de que no hay
alternativa y a partir de ahí cuando hay
unos procesos de radicalización internos
pero también a favorecidos desde el
exterior y empieza también a surgir
movimientos más radicales violentos son
vinculados al terrorismo yihadista
internacional eso dará la excusa también
perfecta al régimen sirio no es para
masacrar con todavía más intensidad
a la oposición oa la rebelión o la
insurrección
como queramos entonces esa capacidad por
parte es la injerencia internacional a
distintos niveles y apoyando distintos
actores en cada uno de los sectores que
estamos analizando en libia siria y
yemen pero también y sobre todo diría
esa capacidad por parte de aquellos que
tenían poder y no quería perderlo para
manipular la situación en su propio
beneficio y para hacer que una parte
hecha por parte de la población quizás
más
cobarde o con más miedo pues acaba ya
acabará prefiriendo que las cosas se
quedarán como estarán que no a avanzar
en el cambio es quizás lo que nos
explica más porque el grado de
frustración y de violencia
ahora hay quienes señalan además que
existe una cierta trama que está
financiada por las denominadas
petromonarquías de la región del golfo
que habían inter invertido enormes
cantidades de dinero no para desactivar
el movimiento revolucionario es esto
efectivamente así igual menos probable
no claro que ya sí además es público y
notorio tampoco se ocultan pero aquí hay
que decir que no han ido solo en una
dirección de petromonarquías por
llamarlas así hay de distinto tipo y que
han apoyado movimientos a veces opuestos
los países del golfo no han mirado
a esta situación de cambio con una misma
visión compartida y el caso más extremo
no sería como hemos visto a qatar
promoviendo esa ola de cambio a través
de distintos medios especialmente lo que
podríamos llamar el poder blando el
software con al yazira
entre otros mientras que otros como
arabia saudí o los emiratos árabes
unidos han apoyado claramente
digamos las fuerzas del antiguo régimen
lo que pasa es que esto tomo sobre todo
a partir del año 2003 no derivada muy
peligrosa en el cual
pero también turquía y todos estos dos
actores plantearon hicieron una
equivalencia entre cambio democracia y
también apoyo a las fuerzas del
islamismo político mientras que
el campo opuesto a con emiratos árabes
unidos y arabia saudí también se le
sumaba en egipto después del
derrocamiento de mohamed morsi la
llegada de afectar sí sí pues se sitúan
en un campo opuesto y por lo tanto
dentro equiparaban no es a las protestas
no ya a un cambio democrático sino a una
voluntad de tirar atrás de
y digamos que la de nombre
la identificación del islamismo político
como el enemigo a batir todo esto ha
hecho que se confundan a menudo los
términos de forma interesada y por lo
tanto hemos visto cómo estas potencias
regionales las del golfo de las que
estabas hablando pues han tenido un
papel determinante en la evolución
política del resto de países de la
región y allí vemos y eso quizás es la
novedad no sólo a una potencia regional
clásica
como es arabia saudí sino también a dos
potencias regionales y emergentes o que
aspiran a ser potencias regionales como
qatar en los emiratos árabes unidos- y
lo más interesante es que estas dos han
apoyado de forma bastante sistemática a
grupos y rivales entre sí y por lo tanto
podríamos decir que los países del golfo
y sobre todo con tantos recursos no han
hecho más que añadir leña al fuego
estuvimos al final de esta entrevista de
actuar sobre la lucha muchísimas gracias
por haber participado en esta entrevista
de france 24 en nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]
y